[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants avez vous été sage
aujourd'hui oui tant mieux nous allons
vous raconter notre expédition dans la
lune gros ours vous montrera les beaux
dessins qu'il ya fait alors tu es prêt
nounours ou lui pas trop givet
roquelaure au pot pour beaucoup de
petits enfants le soir avant de dormir
regarde par la fenêtre et voit le ciel
les étoiles la lune et il pense que la
lune est une dame mystérieuse qui ne se
montre que la nuit mais gros ours et moi
nous avons fait exprès grand voyage pour
vous raconter et vous montrer tout ce
que nous avons vu tu vois tu dis oui la
lune
c'est une grosse boule toute ronde comme
ça et pour y aller nous avons pris cette
belle fusée votre nuage qui nous l'avons
laissé au garage car nous voulions aller
très vite et nous sommes montés sur
cette grosse fusée avant de partir nous
avons passé nos combinaisons et nos
casque de cosmonaute
ça sert à quoi si mon tour
ça j'en sais rien mais ça tient chaud et
le lundi 3 juin à 6h07 du matin notre
expédition destination lune pris son
envol
notre fusée lancée à une vitesse
vertigineuse s'éloigna très rapidement
de la terre dans le ciel on croisait des
milliers des toiles en moins de deux
jours
nous avions parcouru les 400 mille
kilomètres et nous contournons la lune
c'est très loin et c'est beau en nous
approchant nous avons vu de très hautes
montagnes et des lacs tout plat sans eau
d'une couleur grise qui à padoue se sont
pas des là ce voyage ne plaisait pas du
tout à gros ours
il pleurait tout le temps bien su que
j'avais peur moi je voulais rentrer à la
maison et tout à coup au milieu de cet
univers silencieux nous avons entendu un
petit musulman mien ou yahoo
c'était notre ami mines et un seul sans
sa petite fusée
ils s'étaient perdus et ne retrouvait
plus le chemin de la terre
grosso ce fut très content de rencontrer
enfin un être vivant à port saint louis
et comme il avait emmené avec lui sa
boussole et ses jumelles nous avons pu
guider pour le retour ce chaton
aventureux qui avait voulu jouer à
l'homme de l'espace fait tourner la tête
cette histoire mon pauvre ami n'est que
bien failli te perdre je suis sûr qu'ils
préfèrent être ici avec nous n'est ce
pas miner tintin momus différents mais
oui car il est l'heure de faire dodo
allons les enfants au lit
comment ce coup ci vivent là là les
enfants
j'éteins la lumière bonne nuit
monique hos cosmo nikos ou une autre dit
mirabel nous aussi on va construire une
fusée et on y va dans la lui avait tapé
et maman est minime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit futur petit cosmonaute bonne
nuit les enfants mais vous savez elle
est encore plus belle à voir de loin à
l'une qu'en penses-tu bronze ours je
préfère pas trop je préfère à demain les
enfants au revoir madame la lune au
revoir à 2 me
[Musique]